colombia es de lejos el país de américa
latina con más asesinatos de líderes
sociales una conocida verdad que pone
nuevamente de manifiesto la organización
human rights watch en su último informe
los riesgos se dan en los territorios en
las zonas rurales en colombia donde
comunidades indígenas afrocolombianas en
campesinos son extraordinariamente
vulnerables a las amenazas a las
presiones a la extorsión y finalmente
incluso pueden ser asesinados
lamentablemente con impunidad por grupos
irregulares armados por mafias por
guerrillas por grupos disidentes de las
farc el documento señala más de 400
asesinatos de defensores de derechos
humanos desde 2016 pero de acuerdo con
la defensoría del pueblo 710 activistas
han sido asesinados en el país en ese
mismo periodo los asesinatos han
incrementado desde entonces con el
surgimiento de nuevos grupos armados
muchas veces cuando se escuchan de estos
problemas
el gobierno ordena el traslado de tropas
tropas del ejército y esas tropas se
dedican a combatir a los a los bandidos
a los delincuentes que están
precisamente detrás de estos de estos
casos pero no protegen a las comunidades
y la presencia del aparato judicial es
realmente muy precaria la ong pide al
gobierno a aumentar urgentemente la
protección a los líderes y garantizar
que los criminales enfrenten la justicia
subraya que a pesar de la existencia de
leyes para prevenir ataques estás en la
práctica no los protegen días atrás el
gobierno dijo que reforzaría la
presencia militar y judicial pero a
pesar de los constantes llamados de
atención nacionales e internacionales no
ha dado un cronograma detallado de su
plan para garantizar a los activistas el
derecho a la vida